[Music]
nobody's that lucky news true that I
know a few people who are very lucky
like in Spain really like where I'm like
there's no way you think they bring that
on themselves mentality oh yeah but I
feel like they're Ewing I feel like
they're really lucky and their own lives
but then like something else in their
life is off because like they're too
lucky so then there's [ __ ] happening
yeah I've been lucky yeah yeah something
like that
I don't know any lucky people yeah you
lucky no okay I'll share with you who
they are after okay
submitted by what up gangsta what up
dawg hello a man who claimed he had won
the lottery a hundred twenty-three times
that's lucky was forced to pay back four
hundred and seventy thousand euros Oh
cuz he which is nothing if you won the
lottery from 2:120 tARGIT is that why he
he's a psychic and he knew all the
numbers and he's Nothe or he worked for
the lottery nice [ __ ] cheating that's
like where he's got an insider oh four
hundred thousand euros seventy thousand
euros so maybe like six hundred fifty or
something like that yeah yeah that's a
lot of money but not if you want to
actually win the lottery win the lottery
a hundred times but it could be like a
thousand but when you just win the free
ticket yeah [ __ ] picks like the one
with the highest odds of winning like
over and over again but actually so the
problem was was this guy was previously
a convicted criminal and victim money
laundering so he moved to a place in
Solihull or something I looked it up
that's in England and he buys a house
for $400,000 and he buys a house for
$400,000 and people are like what the
[ __ ] you like where did you get this
house you're not working like this
doesn't add up like where's this money
coming from so the National Crime Agency
came down and they said they like hey
man what's up with this he's like oh
well I won the lottery
oh okay where's the doctor oh I wanted
so many times a one in a hundred and
twenty three times totally fine and like
they couldn't really prove anything
never won the lottery he never could you
never won the lottery but it was also
from another country and he was just
like you can't say
I didn't win the lottery what if you're
convicted that if you're felon you can't
do like you can't qualify that maybe
good America but I think you can okay
qualify to pay the lottery food no I
think you can applause I mean like
honestly the lottery what I'm confused
on is if you're a money launderer I
think that that's like a you know what
are they call it high crime or something
white colored white-collar crime right
so you're normally I would think kind of
witty and intelligent why would you just
say you won the lottery once I know
right I guess sounds pretty [ __ ]
unbelievable if you're like I wanted 123
times yeah the odds are insane well he
just needs to win somewhere cuz he
always loses in life it's it's funny
that you say that because he actually if
he purchased it under his father's name
and that was like the first suspicion
that they had so they actually hired the
National Crime Agency to hire a
statistician to prove that there was no
way that this guy could have won the
lottery 123 times when they finally did
the whole like statistics run of it they
said that the chance of him winning this
like whatever the lottery it was 123
times would be as the same as winning
the UK national lottery jackpot forty
weeks in a row like that's what they
narrowed it down to and so that's the
only way that they could like prove that
there's no way you actually want it well
you know where he went
getting them to believe him or not or
challenging enough that they had to hire
all these people to if you would have
just said yeah one at once heap I could
be free probably but I think I was
sketchy that he was convicted for money
laundering and he purchased the house
under his dad's name and like this
doesn't look like it's a particularly
like wealthy City it's not like it's a
little it south of Birmingham shouldn't
have bought it all cash yeah but it it
like to me I'm like four hundred
thousand I'm like that's gonna be a
big-ass house if it's a small town I
don't know I don't know what Europe
houses are purchasing a house under so
your family members name is not that
weird to me yes like you're you can use
their credit at least here in America
you can use their credit co-sign you buy
it all cash it still raises a bunch of
eyebrows the cash thing sure yeah but
yeah yeah late a lot of people that buy
all cash here because their age
like a lot of Chinese people they park
their money you don't believe in the
bank's system over there so they
reported it like say Joe has a house and
I'm coming him and I give him real cash
for his house you don't care you got
your cash you were trying to sell your
house well I don't think anyone reported
it I think it's just during the
investigation where they're like wait a
minute
there's so much money happening here
where's he getting his money like you
know I mean you think there's an
investigation for the money laundering
as I was happy no the investigation was
about the house yeah yeah in the cold
report it's like completely moved in so
it might have been like we don't have
all the details on it but it might have
been the person like you know maybe we
ran a background check because obviously
you're gonna run a background check on
who's buying the thing but it's your
elderly dad and it says that he's 80
years old and you know that the guy you
met was in his early 40s and then also
they pay you cash for this house yeah
foreign like you don't have any record
like he has a criminal called a federal
wire act which was instated in like
[ __ ] 95 or some [ __ ] like that but
anyways any any deposit or money
movement over $10,000 cash has to be
reported to the IRS yeah so that means
in and out of country he's buy a car
yeah when you travel the limit is
$10,000 cash and it's - it was - scoffs
money laundering and drug dealing and
things and regulate the money in and out
to keep our like inflation but I wonder
if that depends on country that's
obviously yeah maybe the UK copied it
yeah maybe because I mean it's pretty
standard here and also it's a bit scary
like when we were selling our house like
we had two bidders that one of them was
gonna he had money sending his
accountant and the other half of
whatever the down payment was coming
from alone and then we had the second
buyer who's gonna pay like 80 percent of
it like in cash and we were like [ __ ]
like that's kind of scary
really that's rare
I'm just say it was scary for us yeah
yeah yeah so then like these kind of
interesting dope to have eight hundred
thousand dollars just in your bank
account for a home and say I'll buy it
alright often I think if it's not a crew
if it's not a real estate crew but I
think sometimes people are selling
houses and do that exactly like you
analysis and you have like yeah are just
moving down sizing up the UPS grading
right it's also like the whole portfolio
of the person one person was like they
had the 20% down but they're from like
Navy Fed which is like you're part of
the Navy and from a credit union I've
heard of that Bank true then you have
someone that's like I'll pay like eighty
percent from Jing Chou Bank not even
here don't worry it's gonna be wired
here on Friday but we went with we went
with the other person because they were
willing to pay over asking
oh that's it just dropped out I don't
know where so we're like wishes should
have gone with the cash but maybe the
Navy fat person yeah yeah yeah but you
know like the title Kobe like America
has all these regulations to handle they
have like the title companies taking
this money before they pass the actual
title and like yeah like I just don't
think cash is that sketchy or we've I
agree well the thing that they predict
that this guy did like either way it was
very illegal was that like if you win
the lottery in Pakistan then you it
takes a long time to get your money so
sometimes people will just sell the
winning lottery ticket so that they get
their cash immediately so they suspect
that using laundered is that laundered
money because maybe you're not paying
taxes on it but if this lottery tickets
worth a million and I make joke a me a
million I'm not paying the taxes on the
million but you'll end up doing it right
so like he so they basically figured
that he must have just bought these
lottery tickets using money that he
didn't actually have and now he's
claiming that he wanted 123 times
there's far a lot of weird stuff with
the lottery there's a movie about that
don't you vote to move around that's
pretty smart
well I mean he's got to pay all this
money back he has to pay back half a
million dollars so it's like basically
with interest I've heard that winning
the lottery is like the worst [ __ ]
thing okay they say there's an America
there's a curse yeah it's not a curse
it's just don't I didn't grow up with
knowing how to manage money and then
they're dumped a bunch of money on so
they don't know how to spend it or where
to put it like they just start spending
it but there's so much money how do you
left that up like if you win like the
real lottery like that's like but that
just goes to show that mostly in say no
money but I just beg
budgeting is literally a personality
trait through and that's what people
don't understand is that I could give
you a million dollars well maybe you can
handle it but a lot of people they
cannot handle overnight and that's the
same thing with anything overnight
success overnight fame its youth we've
seen people squander that yeah they
don't know how to deal with it what's
that show like that 30 broke for 30 or
something like that 30 34 34 34 34 thing
no sports thing does it were they like
they're they're given a bunch of money
okay because they play sports and then
they spend it all and they go broke yeah
yeah yeah you hear those stories all
time yeah yeah one of the 30 30
documentary yeah there's got loaded
there's a log I've heard Allen Iverson's
really struggling in like when you're in
here like the biggest contract ever I
mean it's like yeah like a lot of
celebrities that came from nothing
Johnny dude I read so I read that hit is
like his agents or his money wasn't like
money people actually died yeah they
were telling him for months they were
like hey man you're spending more than
you're making each one slow it down slow
it down and he was having this crazy
lifestyle yeah I heard he's buying like
a property every week anyway like
Nicolas Cage she bought like four
castles and like multiples of each thing
it couldn't just be like one luxury item
it had to be like if you were castles
like to eat a night special or Nicolas
Cage was about his Fendi habits and
there's this one where him and Leo they
went to an auction in their boat and oh
they're selling a skeleton head for 70
G's and they're just out trying to
outbid each other
and I'm like that's [ __ ] crazy like
the the type of lifestyle that they have
that they're getting so amped up about
this piece of thing that is completely
useless yeah but they do have the 70 GS
I think you just start away like nothing
but you do you think you do think people
like that would have liked cuz they
didn't go from 0 to 100 like I even
heard something today I think we're like
cool place Tony Stark Robert Downey jr.
yeah I heard like his first Iron Man he
only made and I say only but like 500k
which is the scale of things was nothing
but then the next one he made like 10
mil and he was like he was
Hollywood for a little bit just was on
trod beside the port they set a point
they said but my point is like these
celebrities don't go from like zero to
100 mil so like a lot of them have the
time to build the team and account on
people you trust and stuff like that
where the lottery like you talked about
like I think if you probably did a
survey of who plays the lottery it might
be people that are down on their luck
don't have a lot of money to begin with
so that makes more sense because you're
literally going from 0 to 100 mil and
then you're buying 20 boats or whatever
but like Johnny Depp and these guys like
keeping up with the Joneses but in my
famous also like there was a post that
Justin Bieber did pretty recently that
was like honestly like super heartfelt
where they loved him dude did you read
he was like I could not handle this
honest like yeah the success happened
over two years but it came hard and fast
and he's like as a child your brain is
not developed to make these decisions
yeah and it's like don't even have life
skills he was right no life skills and
even people and was a loser my mom was a
young mom no one helped me no one gave
me guys yeah and then suddenly I'm on
top of the world and like I didn't have
to develop like all I had was like my
talent and so there's even people that
are 2530 that are struggling in life
emotionally and they're still like
Michael Jackson - yeah like emotionally
stunted still like they're 16 so when
you hand them a million dollars for now
Oh your grandma and your on psych you
let me get a dollar
let me get blood they don't want a
dollar they want like a few g's and you
don't know how to say no you don't know
how to like you know be a little selfish
and protect yourself that's why I'm not
a mega rich God is fair really I want to
be mega rich because why is he fair what
I can't wait to tell people no you can
have nothing no one asks I guess that is
really no you're a hell of rich when
people start asking you for money yeah
cuz if you're like kind of rich like you
know like no one's asking you for money
because they know like oh he's doing
well but he you know I wouldn't even let
them ask don't be like can I know
nobody can't even finish the sentence
yeah
[Music]
[Music]